it's um
our first final in a quad series and
we're facing australia who are the world
ranked number one team so
last night we uh we drew in the dying
seconds of the game um which is a great
story leading into tonight's finals so
yeah it's uh it's been an excellent
series so far for us and we're looking
forward to another go tonight
okay um how do you think you get how do
you think you're going to get on this
evening
i think we'll be better than last night
um but i also think the australian
diamonds will better their performance
so it it really is going to be a tight
one and closely contested uh they've got
their hands on this trophy a number of
times it's always eluded us so we're
pretty hungry to to see if we can lift
that trophy and build more confidence as
we head towards birmingham
okay what what makes the england team so
good
it's their camaraderie uh and they're
currently they refuse to lose attitude
um i think the belief in the group is is
great at the moment we're tracking
really well
i think england teams of old would have
maybe crumbled under the pressures of
that dying 15 minutes yesterday so yeah
i think the camaraderie in this group
their belief in each other and the
collective and the fact that we are
hopefully tracking well and just
disrupting the world order a little bit
more um in recent wins
yeah people shouldn't underestimate
netball it's quite a physical game i
know you're not it's not supposed to be
much of a contact sport but you know
it's a bit rough and tumble on occasion
having been the center at school
yeah i mean they're real athletes um and
incredibly strong and powerful and the
sport itself is is very dynamic it
requires all physical elements and
attributes and i think yes whilst the
rule book says it's a non-contact sport
it's a fully contested sport and that's
the way i guess that we that we play it
um and so you're right you know there's
there's no holds bar with these with
these teams and uh australia are one of
the best at doing that so yeah we'll
have to be strong this evening for sure
okay fantastic a fully contact sport i
like that
description how do you think it's going
to go looking ahead to the commonwealth
games
yeah i mean i think irrelevant of the
scoreline tonight i think we've we've
done really well and we wanted to come
into this quad series having not had one
since january 2019 and be very
competitive in every game um the
scoreboard is obviously everything that
people remember but
we're about preparing for those big
moments and and the biggest stages and
that will be commonwealth games so i
think to have to have beaten south
africa with a a history-making scoreline
to have got past new zealand who are the
current world champions uh and to have
drawn with the current world ranking
number one team last night i think we
there's a lot for us to already be
pleased with um but ultimately this is
the test can we go back-to-back days and
better our performance um in the biggest
stage of this tournament which is the
final so a great dress rehearsal
opportunity for us to to test ourselves
good luck thanks for joining thank you
very much appreciate it thank you